foreign
Clarksville Georgia what's up Rebecca
hey Dr John thank you for taking my call
of course thank you for calling what's
up
so I um am a mom of Siri
um I have two biological and one step
um the one that I'm calling about is my
son who is from my first marriage he is
almost 11.
um so recently he has gotten to where he
will get in the shower and just
essentially rinse off so he won't
shampoo
he won't watch his body listen
your other kids are they daughters
they are okay you have to understand
this from 11 to about 22 soap is
actually uh boys become allergic to soap
oh gosh that's fantastic yes it burns
their skin like lava so just wanted you
to know that just want you to know oh
gosh okay so he's just getting in
rinsing off
are there are there times he gets out
and you say did you use soap and he
looks at you like you're the craziest
stupid person who's ever lived like oh
what
and then you feel me
nuts oh man okay I just interrupted you
so he's just hosing off and then getting
getting out what else
yeah
right
um
body spray
you have to ban it from your home okay
you promised me you'll do that I promise
none none and if you married a guy that
wears ax body spray Rebecca
no body spray there's there's all kinds
of of health reasons well I know but
but no on behalf of all those sweet
Middle School girls no no
get away now yes gosh it's like
secondhand smoke except worse okay so he
does use deodorant so you have a super
hygienic 11 year old let's just put that
out here he already he is wearing
deodorant and he is body spraying
himself what else
um well I mean really you know he's
pretty hygienically
um you know safe I guess you would say
um you know other than you know just not
wanting to use soap um and like you know
of course if I ask him yeah Mom of
course I did and then you know I feel
like the nagging mom who's like okay but
I don't smell any soap right
um so
let me just say this if he is getting
into a shower in a residential area in
Clarksville Georgia and just rinsing off
he is cleaner than 99 of the young 10 to
11 year olds that have ever existed in
the history of this planet just that
okay so from a is he gonna die is he
disgusting uh
he's gonna be fine okay he's he's 11.
yeah all right
there you go
you got to make peace with
in my own life
some things I can say all I want let me
I'll just speak about myself my parents
told me a lot of stuff
and some of it I just had to suffer the
social consequences because I did not
listen
ing because I was 10 or 11 or 16 or 25
or whatever yeah but at some point
someone had to say good God Delona you
stink and I had to go well okay you know
what I mean I had to wear deodorant and
or wash my gym clothes or whatever the
thing was and so I we don't want our
kids to suffer social consequences
they're going they're going to
um
this might sound bananas okay
has anyone ever showed him how to wash
his armpits and how to clean not just
like the outer shiny part of his booty
cheeks but actually washes but wash his
feet and washes hair if no one's ever
shown him how to do it
it may be a he has no road map for this
and for you and me that sounds so dumb
because we've taken 55 000 showers in
our lifetime he hasn't and so he may
just you'd be like you need to use soap
and he may look at you go I don't know
what that means wash your armpits uh I
watched my college roommate I won't out
him which one but
uh I saw him put on deodorant and I was
like what are you doing how did you and
here's what I realized he wasn't an
athlete he hadn't been in a locker room
with hundreds of dudes and seen a
hundred different versions of how people
put on deodorant and and realized oh
there's a way that works in a way that
doesn't work you just didn't have and
never seen that
so I would recommend it's going to sound
awkward and weird and if your husband
would help that would really help but
let's just give him a run through let's
teach him what we're talking about does
that sound fair
it does it does and I mean so prior I
guess I should have given you a little
back story so
um Braden and I it's kind of been uh
since he was about three okay
um and then I got remarried um actually
just this year
um so you know he's kind of a mama's boy
um and I used to always you know go in
there and sit with him while he would
shower and we would talk about his day
and things like that but I had a baby in
September last year
and so you know recently is where the
change kind of happened so I was
wondering you know if maybe this is like
an attention thing where you know Mama's
not with him all the time now is that
what he is missing it I mean it could be
but I wouldn't even good on that road
yeah
um the reality is he's 10 or 11 and 10
or 11 year old boys are not known
globally for their hygienic practices
right and so I I wouldn't I you're
trying to figure out a way to make this
your fault don't do that don't do that
okay okay you had a baby you got to do
what you got to do and the dynamic of
your life your relationship with your 10
year old has changed it's a new dynamic
and so
um if you valued that time with him when
you should just sit and hang out in the
shower which by the way if he's 11
you're getting borderline
right so it would not do that it would
have been time to not have shower time
with Mom or he would have been talking
to one of my colleagues in the next
couple years so here's here's the here's
your responsibilities mom if that time
was valuable to you where do I find that
time again for us
right and for me and my 12 year old we
go to breakfast once a week yeah we go
to Waffle House and we hang out and he
gets to see me over tip and he gets to
see me how I treat the waiter waitresses
and the cooks and so he's learning this
he's soaking all this up and I get to
spend some magic time with him and we
talk about gratitude and Christmas
presents and what things mean and
Science and we talk about a bunch of
stuff I also don't have two little kids
that I gotta deal with and so I'm not
casting that on you that may never
happen for you guys for a while so where
can you find that time is it a walk in
the evening is it some kind of role does
that make sense and I also let me pass
this I'm throwing a thousand things at
you so my mind's spinning here
um I had a professor Dr Aretha marbley
um she's one of my favorite people I've
ever met in my life
she gave me this wisdom whenever um we
had my son Hank and then my wife was
pregnant with Josephine
and she said you can avoid all problems
all of them by simply referring to
your your new baby as his baby she said
just refer to him as his baby
and I was like but it's not she's like
just trust me
and so as soon as my wife started
showing we started talking about his
sister and his baby and how he was gonna
help be a part of raising this young
girl and how he was gonna love her and
show her respect and dignity and what
does that mean and
and now man I got a pretty amazing 12
year old
when it comes to to loving and honoring
and taking care of his little sister
it's not perfect they're still 12 and
six and God help us all but it's pretty
amazing and so you teaching your son
that he's got a role to play
in the lives of these young kids
he they won the the cosmic Lottery
because they got him as an older brother
and then very directly here's what
that's going to look like so you take
him out for a walk or for a breakfast or
a dinner date or something once every
two weeks once a week and say what's one
or two things we can really do to show
the little ones that we love them this
week what's one thing you're gonna do to
love your brother and your sister right
see what I'm saying or your sister and
your sister let's give him some
ownership there right
um and I man that's where I would lean
let's now I want to go down one more
rabbit hole with you okay
nagging and complaining has never solved
anything ever okay yeah absolutely let's
take that out of the equation
um at some point the hygiene may get too
much
okay
at some point he gets to make choices
in in response to your boundaries what
does that mean
your boundaries are I do not take people
to school who have not um bathed with
soap
I do not take people to the movies or to
their practices that have not bathed
with soap
and so if you want to choose to not do
these things and thereby suffer the
consequences of not choosing to do these
things great I'm going to honor that
but you hold the cards here
and it's not your punishment you didn't
do this so you don't get to go I'm not
I'm not going to weaponize your
friendship so I'm not going to weaponize
these things you're going to make
choices
and if I go in the bathroom and the soap
is still dry completely bone dry you
haven't used it your little floofy thing
hasn't it's bone dry then you've just
made some choices that you're not you
don't want to go on that date that you
don't want to go to the movie you don't
want to go to that birthday party and
that's totally fine that's the choice
you made I'm not gonna fight you over it
right right and this is a hard shift
because you've been you've been doing
things for him for a long time
yeah stop feeling guilty about the
divorce stop feeling guilt about this
stuff and let's create let's let's be
about raising an incredible young man
does that sound fair
that sounds perfectly Fair okay one more
thing last one last one last one
I feel like this is me just throwing
stuff at you
this is a bougie answer okay not
everybody can do this if y'all are in a
financial position where this is
possible
take him with you to the store
he let him pick the bar of soap and let
him pick the shampoo he's going to use
let him be a part of it you tell him no
more ax body spray I don't have a
problem with ax person like no more body
sprays we're not doing body sprays gross
uh if we were supposed to have body
sprays evolution of salt for that I know
that was a terrible answer we were
deodorant I know I know internet people
um I was trying to be funny as I said it
I realized I made myself a circular
argument that's not going to work just
no body sprays but
allow him to choose the soap allow him
to choose the shampoo and so he's got
some sort of ownership in this
he gets he's starting to learn the
choices that he gets to make right so
let's give him some autonomy on the
front end and then it becomes did you
use your soap did you use your shampoo
the one that you picked out right so
he's starting to slowly
recognize the weight of his choices and
his decisions which is one of the
greatest gifts you can give any young
kid which is to slowly teach them the
weight of
being alive because it's heavy and the
longer we carry that Forum the more
shock there is when they have to pay
their own bills and make their own
decisions and deal with their rejections
and get their hearts broken all those
things which we all have to do
um man teaching them the weight of their
choices at an early age what a gift what
a gift but
you have a 10 year old or 11 year old
that seems allergic to soap
you're all right you're all right